in the collective memory of the people
Diana Princess of Wales was everything a
role should be she was beautiful
composed and full of compassion for
those in need and when she died in 1997
it was a horrific tragedy that shook the
world she had been robbed of a future
that was looking incredibly bright and
her sons would forever be without a
mother but the dark secrets of Diana's
life proved that all that glitters is
not gold some people believe that her
death was no accidents and it was
actually an elaborate conspiracy
designed by the royal family to silence
her in the biographic slidey we look at
Diana Princess of Wales
[Music]
Danah was born on July the 1st 1961 to
John and Frances Spencer it had been
tradition for members of the nobility to
marry one another for centuries and her
parents were no exception together with
her two older sisters and two brothers
they lived in a mansion called Parke
house in Norfolk England as he can
imagine that I grew up with the best
things that money could buy and she went
on playdates with children in the raw
family but all of the money in the world
can't buy happiness John and Frances
they had a toxic marriage all her life
Diana's parents never said I love you to
one another or indeed to their children
they pushed off most of the parental
duties to nannies or governess's at age
9 her father sent her to boarding school
her mother remarried to a man called
Peter shan't kid who was the heir to a
successful wallpaper company her father
married a woman named Raine mccorkadale
who was the daughter of a famous
remnants novelist the children they
weren't present at their second father's
marriage and they had to find out about
it through the newspaper Diana and her
siblings deeply resented rain as an evil
stepmother and blamed her for tearing
their family apart
diana was a shy girl and she struggled
in school she was labeled as of the
thick one by her family and this was
enough for her to end up crying in
school every time she got a bad grade
deep down all she really wanted was to
be loved and accepted for who she was
and dreamed of a prince who was going to
take her away so she could live happily
ever after
[Music]
when she was just 16 years old Diana met
Charles the Prince of Wales for the
first time he was 29 and dating her
older sister Sarah the relationship
between Sarah and Charles it never went
anywhere so they went their separate
ways however Charles said that Diana
made a big impression on him because he
thought she was very cheerful and
beautiful when she came of age Diana
could have chosen to party like a
socialite or travel the world with her
family's wealth but when she was 18 she
chose the very normal life of working as
a kindergarten teacher she used her own
paychecks to share an apartment with a
few friends
Diana loved taking care of children and
it made her very happy to give them the
love and encouragement that she never
got as a little girl at that time Dinah
was filled with a lot of hope about her
future she said that she felt this deep
sense of destiny and but one day she
would grow up to do great things
Prince Charles had been dating several
women over the years including Camilla
Rosen riche and Camilla was not wife
material in the eyes of the Queen so she
married a multi-millionaire named Andrew
Parker Bowles but Charles and Camilla
had never actually broken off their
relationship and they continued having a
secret affair the entire time that she
was married Charles was now in his 30s
and under a lot of pressure from his
mother who'd settle down and produce an
heir he needed a wife that was a member
of the aristocracy and Diana had all of
the qualifications are perfectly
acceptable bright after going on only 13
dates Charles proposed to Diana when she
was a barely legal 18 year old even
though they hardly knew one another Anna
felt as though becoming the princess was
the sense of Destiny that she had been
waiting for all along a couple of weeks
after their engagement the couple was
interviewed by the press towards the end
the reporter said that they were very
much in love Diana replied of course
Charles laughed saying whatever in love
means watching the tape you can clearly
see that Diana was heartbroken in later
interviews diana defines that instance
as the moment she knew that marrying him
would be a huge mistake however the
entire world had their eyes on her and
she knew it was her duty to go through
with the marriage even to this day Diana
and Charles still go down in history for
having one of the most expensive
weddings experts estimate that today
their wedding would cost anywhere from
70 to 100 million dollars from the
perspective of the people watching the
wedding on TV it's
seems like a dream come true dianna
later said it was the worst day of my
life their honeymoon was on the Royal
Yacht Britannia where Diana reportedly
spent most of the time sleeping in 1982
Charles and Diana had been married for
less than a year and she had already
discovered Charles's secret relationship
with Camilla parker-bowles he started to
Gaslight her saying that she was
paranoid this made her so devastated
that she threatened to kill herself
Charles ignored her and started to leave
to go on a horseback trip
Diana threw herself down the stairs the
Queen rushed to her aid screaming for a
doctor
while all of the attendants surrounded
the princess Charles just kept on
walking to the outside world the
marriage between Diana and Charles
seemed like a fairy tale that come to
life for the first time people around
the world were fascinated and invested
in the raw couple no matter what was
going on behind closed doors she had to
smile wave and just pretend that
everything was fine
[Music]
Diana was still just a teenager when she
was put under pressure by the media to
be this perfect princess combined with
her unhealthy marriage it was enough to
make a spiral into a deep depression and
she became bulimic she had so much
empathy for other people that a
particularly difficult meeting visiting
the poor sick and wounded made her
mental health a lot worse instead of
recognizing that she needed help diana
was treated like a child throwing a
tantrum and the royal family just
continued to ignore her issues William
was born when Diana was 20 years old
just barely out of her teenage years she
was supposed to raise the future King
little William brought a loss of joy and
purpose to her life during interviews
the press would mostly ignore her while
they spoke with Charles only to ask
Diana how the baby was doing even though
this was actually very demeaning to her
Diana's face would light up and she
would gush about how much fun she was
having with him even after giving birth
to the heir her relationship with her
husband's remains cold and distant she
eventually decided that if she was going
to be stuck in an unfaithful marriage
she would have an affair - when she was
23 Donna fell in love with a cavalry
officer named James who it they were
together
about a year before her second son Harry
was born in pictures showing the two of
them side-by-side it is easy why people
believe that James who it might actually
be Prince Harry's biological father this
is such a popular theory that it was
even turned into a stage play that was
performed on the West End
Diana pushed Charles to be more involved
in raising the boys instead of relying
totally on nannies when the boys were
old enough to go out she made sure they
had normal experiences like water parks
McDonald's and shopping she also brought
them to homeless shelters to pass out
hot tea and food Prince Charles he
scoffed at these ideas asking why all of
that was necessary when she was 25 diana
fell in love with her bodyguard barry
mannakee
they became best friends and she felt
very safe around him he brought a lot of
joy to her life but diana claims that
they never actually crossed the line
however most people still consider this
to be an emotional affair or at the very
least once their friendship was revealed
Prince Charles fired menurkey not long
after leaving his job at the royal
palace barry mannakee was killed in a
motorcycle accident Charles and Diana
were on their way to the can film
festival in France when he told her the
news Charles mentioned monarchies
so casually It was as if he was talking
about the weather
Diana wanted to cry if she knew that
within a few moments she would have to
step out of the car and be photographed
by hundreds of people so she had to put
on that smile once again and just
pretend like nothing was wrong she later
said I think he was bumped off but we'll
never know
Dinah felt that if she did not escape
the marriage she really might want to
take her own life she knew that her only
hope that getting a divorce would be to
get the public on her side it was at
this point that she decided to speak
with a journalist named Andrew Morton
about the truth of the dysfunctional
household Morton eventually published
her biography he called a Diana her true
story in her own words for the first
time in history the public got a glimpse
into the life of a royal marriage and
certainly wasn't pretty
Charles responded by being interviewed
for a documentary in 1994 called Charles
the private man the public role where he
admitted he had an affair with Camilla
parker-bowles Diana responded by doing
an interview on BBC Panorama in 1995
during this interview she said that she
believed Charles was not a good person
and he wasn't even fit to become the
next king of the United Kingdom she
believed that her son William would do a
much better job serving the people Dinah
said of herself that she wouldn't go
quietly saying that's the problem I'll
fight to the end
you
[Music]
Diana and Charles were separated for
years and were seeing other people
after the Pickering back and forth in
the media the Queen herself demanded
that they needed to officially get
divorced in 1995 diana began dating an
egyptian millionaire named dirty fired
his father was the owner of these
successful Harrods department store and
has the net worth of 1.6 billion dollars
which by the way is far richer than the
Queen Charles and Diana were officially
divorced in 1996 Charles would
eventually go on to marry his longtime
girlfriend Camilla parker-bowles
even after leaving her position as
Princess of Wales Diane OTT wanted to
continue her destiny by making a
difference to the world
she was pretty terrible at public
speaking which really was necessary
during charity events and public
appearances so she started to receive
vocal lessons from a former actor named
Peter settlin during the lessons settle
and set up a camera to record her
progress and he asked her questions
about her personal life these became
like much-needed therapy sessions for
her she revealed secrets about her
marriage in the royal family through
these lessons with settlin she was able
to find her own voice and learn to
thrive as a public speaker after her
death these tapes were confiscated by
the royal family and the public were not
able to see them until years later diana
she became a traditional celebrity
without the benefit of royal security
the paparazzi continued to follow her
and write about her in the tabloids
instead of allowing the press to only
write about her hair and fashion choices
she decided to make the best of being in
the spotlight by getting involved in
courses that matter tad she raised
awareness about the AIDS epidemic and
travelled to several African countries
to fight for the end of landmines in
public spaces one of the most famous
photographs of her was with a young
amputee who had had a leg blown off
almost immediately after getting the
attention of the press the laws about
landmines they were changed however this
was making a lot of politicians unhappy
they said that she was getting involved
in issues that she didn't fully
understand her response was that she
really didn't care she was going to
fight for the people and not the
politicians instead of wilting into
quiet obscurity diana she was thriving
she was no longer bulimic or depressed
she was glad to trade her title for a
life of freedom she auctioned off all of
her designer gowns and gave millions to
chair
that she cared about all of this and he
made the public love her more and she
was still a princess in the hearts of
the people
after her divorce was finalized Diana
was dating an Egyptian man named Dodi
fired he was a multi-millionaire who
lived a very glamorous life paparazzi
took photos of them on vacations around
the world the British press called him a
playboy and wrote negative connotations
about the fact that he was Muslim he was
actually a successful movie producer who
was best known for the oscar-winning
movie crook starring Robin Williams he
was also the heir to the multi-billion
dollar Harrods department store fortune
the two of them were very much in love
and they plans on someday getting
married some even believe that Diana and
they have been pregnant with his child
if this was true it would have caused a
lot of issues for the royal family the
idea that William and Harry could have a
muslim half sibling it was unacceptable
she was also threatening to reveal more
and more secrets about the royal family
to the press a charity work as well it
often interfered with money-making
schemes among the nobility indeed she
even received death threats on a regular
basis not long before her death Diana
wrote a letter to her Butler saying that
she believed her ex-husband Charles was
trying to have her killed in a car
accident she also called dirties father
Mohamed al-fayed and told him the same
thing on August the 31st 1997 Dodi Fayed
and Diana were being driven through
Paris by a man named Omri Paul just as
they entered the armored tunnel they
were apparently running from paparazzi
and ended up in an accident for whatever
reason every single one of the security
cameras inside the tunnel just so
happens not to be working that day so
there is no recording showing exactly
what happens according to witnesses the
car went into a pole at 65 miles per
hour and no one was wearing a seatbelt
on September the 6th 1997 the streets of
London were lined with people mourning
Princess Diana's death millions didn't
watch the funeral procession on TV there
all court held a trial and found that
the crash was simply an accidents
however everyone present at that trial
was obligated to side with the royal
family and their findings many people
think they were totally biased
however in 1999 the French government
also investigated the car crash and they
came to the same conclusion there was
simply an accident however in 2008 a new
independent investigation found that the
driver honorary Paul had been drinking
heavily that day in the original trial
had failed
mention that they also concluded
paparazzi vehicles were in fact
tailgating the car the jury concluded
that honoree pole was responsible for
the deaths and that if he was still
alive he would be convicted of
manslaughter for some this investigation
was not enough and one of those people
was dodi's father Muhammad are fired he
had spent years of his life struggling
with racism while running his business
and he was disgusted by how the media
was portraying Dodi even though he was a
victim to Mohammed al-fayed claimed that
he had evidence for 175 separate
conspiracy theories and paid for a
documentary called unlawful killing to
cover them all obviously in this video
we can't go too deep into all of the
conspiracy theories but it was enough
for the British government to ban the
documentary from being seen in the
United Kingdom according to these
conspiracy theories honorary poll was
actually sober that day because the
receipts from the hotel showed that he
only had two drinks at dinner and had
gone through a medical exam by security
beforehand he had actually outrun the
paparazzi and a mysterious white Fiat
Uno followed them into the tunnel with a
group of motorcycles some believe that
these were mi6 agents who were being
paid by the government to kill her after
inspecting the car they discovered that
the seat belts in honorary Paul's car
had been tampered with which is why no
one was wearing them it also took over
an hour and a half for the ambulance to
get to the hospital even though they
were very nearby doctors believe that if
Diana was wearing her seatbelt and had
gotten medical attention sooner she
would have survived unfortunately
without video tape of the crash we may
never know the whole truth of the
circumstances surrounding her death
today Princess Diana she's not truly
gone because she lives on in Prince
William and Prince Harry's legacy
because of her they both do charitable
work and they married for love instead
of finding a mate inside of the royal
family and we're sure that if she could
see them today she would truly be proud
so I hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this twice a week so hit that
subscribe button and you'll learn all
about those when they come out and as
always thank you for watching